christopher chanterai bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce matin au lendemain de cet accord
historique
on l'a vu avec le sujet d'hélène
masquelier certains points restaient
encore en question quel est votre
sentiment c'est que dans les prochains
jours les états membres de l'union
européenne doivent décider de
l'application provisoire de l'accord
d'ici 1er janvier est ce que quelque
chose peut encore coincés oui il ya
encore quelques quelques détails qui
peuvent coincer parce que le parlement
européen n'aura pas le temps de se
prononcer sur cet accord donc il va
falloir que le conseil
adobe l'adoptant provisoire et après
comme c'est un accord mixte il va y
avoir la nécessité que les parlements
des états membres
la prouve également y compris les
parlements des sous parlement des dpi
fédéraux comme la belgique on a vu
l'attitude du parlement wallon
il ya quelques temps qui a bloqué
l'accord avec le canada donc c'est pas
encore c'est pas en cours la faim qui
sont les grands gagnants de ce deal qui
sont les grands perdants peut-être les
pêcheurs européens les grands perdants
dans finalement puisque avec une
variable d'ajustement non parce que jean
castex on se souvient ce bien disait le
contraire lors de son récent déplacement
à calais et à boulogne sur mer il ya 25%
lisait dans le sujet de d'hélène
masquelier qu'ils devront reverser plus
tard d'ici cinq ans aux britanniques
y'a pas de grands gagnants il y à des
des petits gagnants et des même pas il
ya surtout le perdant 1 par rapport à la
situation antérieure au 23 juin 2016
or si on compare avec les su qu'ils
étaient quand même possible de ces
négociations qui habitait qui avouent
qu'ils pouvaient aboutir à no deal
là vraiment c'est bien c'est par rapport
à nos deals qui ont été une catastrophe
nous avons quelque chose mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas une victoire il n'y a
pas de grands gagnants alors pour les
pêcheurs les heureusement qu'il n'y aura
pas de droits de douane londres où donc
selon vous ce n'est pas la panacée c'est
un moindre mal c'est ça surprendre mal
avec simplement oui oui par rapport à ce
que d'ailleurs la commission vient de
publier des ddd comparaison des c'est
très facile à comprendre et à retrouver
sur le site la commission européenne
la comparaison avec la situation avant
le 23 juin quand le loup rem unis
étaient pleinement membres de l'union
européenne et il la situation après donc
avec tout ce qu'on a perdu notamment les
droits citoyens parce que moi je
représentais humblement les citoyens
britanniques étaient bien en france ne
l'a nous avons perdu certains droits de
beaucoup un thé heureusement conservé
par l'accord de janvier 2020 un accord
de retrait mais nous sommes privés
encore 2
la reconnaissance des qualifications
professionnelles nous sommes privés de
la possibilité de fournir des services
la dette prestataires de services avec
un autre pays que nous le pays de
résidence
donc ça concerne les traducteurs les
interprètes les guides touristiques et
quoi d'autre beaucoup debout d'autres
secteurs et puis nous allons surtout
nous perdons le droit d'aller s'établir
dans un autre état membre à ce que nous
avons perdu la citoyenneté européenne
qui nous était très précieuse à vos
côtés on voit également des images de
pêche l'union européenne semble avoir
fait des concessions considérables non
on l'a dit les pêcheurs et les fameux
25%
mais il ya aussi le conseil conjoint
pour les futurs litiges et la cour de
justice européenne qui n'aura pas son
mot à dire
oui nous avons peu de détails sur les
les instances nouvelle qui serait mise
en place pour adjuger les différends qui
pourraient se
qui doit exister pour la pêche qu'il n'y
aura pas de droits de douane bon les
pêcheurs de français belges danois et
autres qui pêchent dans les eaux
britanniques ou français des pêcheurs
britannique qui vendent leur pêche en
france je me déporte par les deux
n'auront pas le spectre wadoux du risque
d'avoir des droits de douane élevés 16 %
18 % selon l'espèce sur le les poissons
qu'ils essaient de vendre au français ou
belge est donc mal mais à mon avis il y
avait eu ça cette vente de 70% de la
production des pêcheurs britannique ne
seraient pas vendus ne serait pas du
tout actrice tiff
c'est bien qu' il y ait eu à un accord
sur la pêche c'est vrai ça être
contestée de partout et une fois de plus
c'est moins bon la situation est moins
bonne qu'avant
comment réagit la population britannique
vous qui représentez les britanniques
établis en france mais du côté
de l'angleterre et du pays de galles
l'irlande du nord et des gosses 1 par
exemple on sait que les cotes prépare un
référendum d'indépendance un pur
notamment réintégrer l'union européenne
je paye de contacts directs à cause de
noël avec beaucoup de monde
ma famille donc je ne sais pas trop mais
c'est vrai que politiquement en écosse
ça alimente la le mouvement vers
l'indépendance écossaise
la première ministre écossaise
d'amsterdam
on a parlé elle en profite pour faire
des discours pour essayer de 2-2 du
gouvernement de londres de l'ensemble i
oi est muni de deux d'obtenir un
référendum s'il ya un référendum
j'espère que le gouvernement britannique
va réfléchir à l'électorat et ne pas
commettre la même erreur qu'en 2016
parce que quand on tient un référendum
il faut inclure dans le lectorat toutes
les personnes qui risquent d'être
impactée par le résultat or
l'indépendance de l'ecosse entraînerait
la le démantèlement du royaume uni donc
c'est tous les citoyens enduré une loi
nome unis qui doivent pouvoir voter pas
que les résidents écossais en 2014
ça a été fait avec le la liste
électorale dae des autorités locales
donc il est résident qui normalement
veut très dans les municipales mme pour
les candidats qui seraient mieux gérer
la collecte des poubelles c'est pas la
même chose c'est une grande question
c'est une grande question d'ordre
d'ordre national beaucoup de questions
qui vont donc rester en suspens malgré
donc cet accord conclut je dis merci
beaucoup christopher chanterai d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le vice-président de
l'association british community
committee of france